[Music]
and
[Applause]
ah,
good afternoon, good afternoon,
welcome back and thank you for attending this
session within the
infrastructure track entitled server
computing options with with google cloud
platform, well my name is rafael sánchez,
I am casto melli nier in google cloud and
here in this session we are going to see
computing options of what is
called server what you have attended
the rest of the track today
you see that we have been raising the
level of abstraction a little from the beginning
except for the first session that  It has
been a bit more generic,
first we saw a session of cv vernet is
where the continuous interaction with
virtual machines etcetera then
we went to cuban test and container
engine that is to say basically containers
the session from before just the one from
before that of my colleague Jorge Nogales  and
capsid has been about the app engine and
in this one we are going to go up one
more step the level of extraction we are going to
talk first  Mainly good about cloud
functions and other series of
computing options called server les
server is buzzword boots word in
English there are many definitions of being
velez and perhaps we should start
there by trying to define what it is to
be see them or what it is  what we understand in
google as how to be green, as I say, is
currently a buzzword in
recent months because it has been a
very sought-after word because everyone wants to
know what this is about being to see them and that it does
not imply that it does not imply this to
reserve them  the thing is that I don't use
servers that I didn't configure them that I
don't have access to them what does this mean
of being green in fact it has been in
recent months here is a graph
of google trends on this word in
particular to see how interest has
been growing  Well, quite a lot
in the last 15 and 18 months of
not looking for practically anything, of not
having, of having a very low interest in
that word, well, fix  hoops to the interest has
grown has grown in a
significant way no then we are going to
start there we are going to try to define what it
is to be velez or what it is that
we understand by being see them then
talk about the servile products that
we have in google cloud  platform
later I am going to compare two technologies
cloud functions and fire with fire they are not
comparable technologies the truth because
one is what is called an area
works as a service bought with back end
as a service which would be fire you know something
much broader than just a
cloud  function but well we are going to
try to compare them and we are going to make a
couple of demos with each one of them is
how to create a faction chaos in the gp in
google and others on how to create a
faction with fire you see and conclude with
a demo in which  I will ask you
for collaboration to send sms to a number
and we will see an application made with a great
faction how simple it can
be to do something with cloud functions and
generate  a complex application,
well, well, we are going to start with the
first one with the first
of the parts on the agenda we are going to
define what it is to be see them and to try to define what it is to
serve them I am going to
start with an example try to
explain it with an example that is the
Next, imagine that you have to
develop an application that, well,
takes from different fronts,
both mobile and stop, because it
collects text
information, video information, and has to store it,
if we have to develop an
application like this, the best thing to do
first  we would think it would be I am going to take a
virtual machine it deployed the corresponding packages it
built the code it
generated the application to a database
to store the text the images
etcetera and that's it
the application would have it the theory
built if this application is
successful it starts to grow what happens  Well,
I will have to grow in terms of
virtual machines, trends,
virtual machines for the pr  Obviously a
balance where a load balancer
loads it before and well, try to cover
that new demand for requests that are
received by the client part,
not by the mobile or
stop part, etc. If this continues to grow,
probably because the architecture will
start it starts to get complicated
maybe to handle the requests
because instead of simply having a
load balancer I have something more
sophisticated for example an
input virtual machine that then
through a messaging system
sends the requests to the  different
machines not in any case the
central part because as you can see it begins to get
complicated as
my application tends to grow and
what gets complicated is this
intermediate part that perhaps has little to
do with my core business what
interests me is what  What would interest me would be to
try to get rid of that
intermediate part, to focus more on the
mobile part or even on  the
database part or in my clients in
general but the idea would be to look
for something to try
to reduce my participation in
that intermediate part as much as possible because of course these
are virtual machines is to think later
when I have to update it
I have to modify them man could
use the  continuous traction system
that we see that we have seen before but in the
end it is a job that
I also have to do, the ideal is that this
part be reduced to a minimum and everything is
scaled, traffic splitting, well, it would be
as simple as possible, ideally
something like
that, that is to say  a mobile application and a
code where it uploads where a site where
I can upload the code
then this would be extracting it to the
maximum making it as simple as
possible if it would be a platform
where to put the code and that would make me
serve those applications that I mentioned
before
yes  It happens to you, I ask if you can think of any
google product that could fit,
for example, in this architecture  ture
something that we could put here to
cover this in this type of this type of
application without needing to worry
about virtual machines
I have the clue we have seen it in the
session before
I actually learned learning something it is
a tool that could could be
executed here  it could could be installed
here to implement this is this
application because it is not an application
it is a product that I deploy
the code as
Jorge has explained to us before any type of code
with any type of application and it
could scale up I could split traffic
and  another series of things that it does
to a rock and without the need to worry
about the servers because of the
infrastructure that is
underneath, then this could be the
first approximation to what we have
for a server, we could think of them, well,
this is something that can be
be considered as being velez a pendin
I do not worry about the servers
especially the part of the  version of
standard app engine and I can implement
I can make one I can deploy an
application like this but in
reality
and I already say it complies with all of them you have
all these features a
fully managed system where I don't have
to apply patches it is operated 24/7
by engineers from  google that autoscale
easy to deploy and with a lesson
from atlanta is about languages because very broad
we have not seen swift and hyper that are n
t within the stand
rd rankings of app engine so we co
ld think that app engine is a serve
product good for us because we lack
define precisely what it is to be seen
good to be seen can be defined as
an architecture that has the
following attributes
that it has no obvious servers and that I
don't have to configure servers I
don't have to worry about servers
I don't even have to think that I have
servers for  below
pay per use is an architecture where
I have a pay per resource use  s
consumed scale as needed
and is based on events, that is to say that what
is executed in some way comes from
a trigger that has been launched and that
produces the execution of that code that
I have stored, so these
would be the three or four attributes  what
an architecture should meet is to
see them in these four attributes
are are the attributes that at least
an architecture srl
velez app engine should meet meets at least three of
the four and of course then
all four have to be met it has to meet
three enough with  that it meets three
or two is enough to see from
our point of view at least the
first three have to meet that
and we could consider that a
product less from our point of view is that
being to see them if it meets the fourth it would already be
a  architecture one hundred percent be
see them an architecture be see them be
full velez no then in google that it
adopt font we have the two product
ranges  the ser velez products that
meet the three with the first three
attributes and ser velez products that
meet the four do not
then products for example that
meet the three attributes that I
mentioned before that I don't even have to
configure servers that scale and pay
per use  Well, one of them, for example, is
bit query, not our data analytics platform,
which allows us to query
enormous databases of terabytes in
seconds and petabytes in the
environment of minutes, it
is basically ours, our
analytics tool for SAP, for
example, the systems  Messaging is
another of the products that is also to be seen,
I can configure many topics, many
many topics where, well, publishers,
that is, the systems that send the
messages, send them there and then
subscribe to them, they consume them, I do not have
to be any type of any type  of
servers and another product also that
is the velez where you did not configure
servers in our servi
managed cloud service more in learning and
there, well, I upload my I can upload the
models I can upload the data so
that these models feed it
and all of that is managed
without the need to configure servers
in fact we have a wider range of
products that we could consider to be
green that at least meet those
three attributes that I mentioned before and
they range from the app engine that was
one of the first products that
we launched in google cloud big query that
was just mentioned by cloud is thorax that
our service of
object storage is also completely ex
server them in the sense that you don't have
to operate pay per use servers and it
also scales
claudia tractor our database service is
not related to cloud data
flow
join the for both bach and
streaming for sap  that I have just
commented that our
cloud messaging system is more in learning and he
left me these two  for the end because
these two are the two
google cloud products that follows would meet
the four with the four
architecture attributes that we have seen in the
previous slide these 4
would meet the fourth of the
attributes which is based on events
is  say that they are launched due to
events and it is on those two that I
am going to focus throughout the
presentation first I am going to talk about
cloud functions in google cloud and then
the fire you see as a platform not
only supports caf action by itself
but it has another series of another
series of capabilities,
well, let's see those two, those two
products that, as I said, are the two
that do comply with the four
server attributes, including the
event one, which is cloud functions cloud
factions  it's a google cloud
product it's a product that's in beta as
of today and can basically be defined
as a brain environment to
build and connect services in  the
cloud with code with code that you
develop complies with the three
characteristics that I mentioned before
of a server architecture confers
servers for nothing even think
about them or configure them in
any way automatically scales
pay per use and also complies with the
fourth  of the requirements that it is the one that
can be launched through
events and what is this so here it
is that they can launch that code what
exactly is this because
certain events can occur certain things in
the cloud environment that are  Those who
execute my function for example
in the case of cloud store is that sometimes
in another storage service if
someone uploads a file to cloud storage
that can serve as a trigger to
launch the code of my function to
execute my function for example me
I could upload a csv file to cloud
storage and that would launch a function
that could make certain changes to me within
the csv file, that is, it is in  the
cloud function the function the function is
executed when I upload a file
automatically is the trigger let's say
that it launches the execution of the code or
in the case of knowing that our
messaging system when I receive
a message from someone in a topic well
at  receiving that message launched is
automatically launched in the execution of the
code of my function
that would be, for example, another trigger that
could launch the execution of the code
that I have in cloud functions so
that is the concept of based on events
of executed according to the code is
execute when it receives a series of
events
but also the execution of the code
can be simply calling a
url calling a url http slash
whatever can also produce the execution
of that function not for that reason also another
of the events is what  we put
here what we see here from http source
simply by calling new relay
the function is executed but this is
from the h deb  e functions and web
books that basically webs are a url
is that I configure my application and that
allows the execution of that code is
those web books open up a world of
possibilities because basically with
urls anyone can launch the
execution of my code and we can  to think
that third-party applications that may
be from google or not from google can
launch the execution of my code that
is stored in con faction, for
example, imagine that I receive a
new email or that I upload a file to google
drive or that it receives an input from me
I calendar based on this type of
events with http with functions the
conclusions that are launched that have the
http trigger could launch it
and even google applications but
third
-party home automation applications or for example an application
that I sent sms messages to a server
if that  server has the capacity to
support web books could launch in the
execution of my code in cloud
functions so it is not only the
trigger  it comes from cloud products
such as when it is now made
cloud afra google clau products
but in the execution of the code it
could come from third parties, that is,
third-party third-party companies that offer
a service and that have the option
of hearing when something happens  in my service
launch a game [ __ ] and the code is executed
in kansas
then we will see a couple of examples of
them
well cloud function is based on laws
for now it is the only supported language it
is the one that factions uses in
nou because of the advantages it
has in terms of  to the number of
libraries that exist that are
available for developers and
also because it has a
very powerful non-blocking environment so it is for
now the language we use to
support cloud functions what
use cases we can have we can think of cal
thanks jones well the  first the one for the one
for the web books is not to say that
third-party applications for example
github github those that the programs  what
you have in mind about hub you know that
perhaps it has nine submenus it has
a website
so you can configure it so that
if someone, for example, makes a comic about
some project, they could throw you a
lime funkshion for example in the gp in
google cloud
another case  of use is to set the
http field in point as I have commented before
that simply in the execution of my
code it is done because someone has
called a url simply for that reason
join the light, that is to say a transformer
of for example the case of the csv that
uploads it  to cloud storage and that is a trigger
for a function for a cloud function
and executes certain modifications on
that csv or deletes columns or adds
new ones or better deletes certain
records etc. It could also be
used as a trigger for in this
case  use for a light été l
and in jute applications with compass up
also us and jute devices for
example start sending messages I
can launch cloud factio  Depending on the
messages that I receive, well,
to do certain things and in general, the
power of all this comes in that, of course,
at the end, with the http pse being the
url, I could integrate with many more
product events that I have or
simply  these products have
to support what they hear because every time
something happens in their environment they are
able to launch a url with parameters
it is also a url it is an hdp ghetto an
hdp post with certain parameters so that
in my crowd function they execute
well one  faction class is very is
quite simple in terms of
code here we have for example
a heater with three lines of
code that basically when I called
a url it will respond with a
message audi fan server is not this
would be  Well, probably because of the
simpler cloud faction,
the trigger is simply executed, it is the call to a
url, so when I execute it, if I
upload these three lines of code
and it is  executed this in a browser because
basically to answer
that what is configured is what is
written in the code above then
notice that with three lines of code
with those three only lines of code
I have what puts an hdp on the left
point
a public the ifai domain that is to say it gives me
just in that domain that you see there I am
central one such
an ssl certificate you see that the request
is https and auto scaling and I will
not worry about anything I
can call this function 100,000
times  that the fan housing server is going to answer me
with all that if you mind with
those t lines of code because I have
I get all those things
as I know how we can see this in cloud
functions as we could see it well
in cloud functions if you see here
I go  to make the screen big you have to
be a little better
to access each faction within
gsp you have the menu on the left
with the different google
cloud products and one of  they are cloud functions
cloud function that has to be
here is inside the computation part
is cloud functions and then
here we would access the submenu to create
the different functions create a cloud
function s well as simple as
giving it a name in the life of  sea here next
adrid I cho
se the regions the product is for sale
nd for now it is only available in th
usa region but as soon
s it is released globally it will be in the r
st of the regions the memory the type of tr
gger that I want it to launch  the
function the execution of this code
initially because it can be launched when
someone sends a message to a topic
within sap when someone uploads a
file to the cloud storage but in this
case I am going to take the option of it
http 3a as you can see it is going to  give a
public to the ifai do my name
automatically and a url to access and
then there is the code itself if the code that
I want to be executed already has the it
generates a package points jas  on
automatically and the code that I want
to be executed then here you
can see a little more
then here I have the code that I
can modify and I can edit it you
can remove it directly here in
the browser or as Jorge Jorge has
shown before with ap that  there
are also editors obviously that I
can do it locally and then and
then upload it so the good thing about it is that it has
hooks is that it
automatically parses the request objects and
responds http here I don't have them so
if for example I wanted to create a
function that's fine  Apart from
simply replying with a hello,
replying with a hello with a name or
something, well, it would be simply, well,
put a few lines of code.
in the
event that in the event that the call
to the action put it or it is
empty I put rafa I put it to generate
a message for me,
a very sophisticated one  cado and then that's it and
basically with this I can
deploy it and it would answer me well, hello
rafa or hello the parameter that I put
inside it
http inside the http request another
thing that cloud function also has is
that it has as you see there  console what
is the command to insert them
directly into cloud blogging say the
product that contains all the blogs
of all google cloud products and I
could also insert for example
error any error command that I
wanted in
also within google
cloud blogging  then with this
and selecting the bouquet where I am going to
display these, store
this function, I click create and in a few
seconds it will create me soon about
20 seconds it will create this function for me and
this function will already be available
through a url  and I will be able to click
and he will answer me, I hope because what
I have written to him before is displaying
but it is displaying in this region and a
few seconds it will be e  n green and I can now
directly
access the function well here to the menu to the
number of requests to one to a kind
of dashboard you can access the code to
the source code since there is the url that
generates me no so if I give it here then
it gives me the  hello rafa that since
written in the code and if I wanted to put
a command a parameter sorry inside
the url for example in this one it would
return the dutch madrid which is the
parameter that I have put then this
with this line of code that
basically  that I have said what I have said to
do does not take the name parameter or else
put or the plus the plus the name
as I mentioned before cloud
function is not a separate product it is
integrated into all the
gcp products with which it adds all the
capabilities  of login and monitoring
that the rest of the gcp products have if
I want to insert any
log command to see it in the google cloud console,
then simply with the
consol dot l command  ove as we have seen before
then we insert any any blog
within the within the console the
same for the same for the errors and
in the monitoring topic I
could also monitor the number of
requests that I am receiving in this
cloud functions see the
execution times the  memory usage that
the code is generating for me, etc. the
heating can either be edited in the
code, or the browser can be removed,
or if you want to use your
favorite editor, well, you still write
the code and then with a command it
displays it in the  deployed in the cloud and
with this command you could
perfectly deploy the code you have in the
cloud
well then summarizing with these five
lines of code with the code that
we have just implemented we have had a
complete url with an execute with a
public flip has deferred my  name
we have an automatically
generated certificate you see that the request is from https
autoscale and at no time have I  We
had to configure any type of
instance servers or something
like that and it is a code that is, well, I already
said, it is event driven, it is and it is based on
events, it is launched when I type
the url in the browser, well this
would be the example of  cloud functions with
a thriller based on http but I
commented before that
gcp causes also support compas up triggers or
with cloud storage an example of code
with a cloud functions
that will be launched by an event in each
story would be the following imagine
uploading a photograph  clarified this
now again our
object storage service as I mentioned before this
would launch the execution of a
code of mine in cloud functions that for
example could execute our app
and image recognition so that
it would return to me the labels that it
sees on the  corresponding image that is to
say that I could upload the
file again that file launches a caf action
the functions are removed the  code that it
has is the execution of our
maxim learning service, which is the
image recognition service and that
returns a series of labels with
probabilities on that photo, not in
this case, because this animal is a rack,
etc.
This in code is these lines  that is to
say with this
we would do exactly what is
described in the previous
slide basically what the code does is
when it detects
when it detects the upload of the
file
the function is executed that what it returns to me
is 2a the function the call the
pgje is that vision point of the vents key
and writes to the console with sun point log
because all the answers I have
obtained from the request for
image recognition as simple
as this above is the library
that it makes use of as  You know,
as mentioned before, no laws have an
impressive number of bookstores,
with which, of course, the bookstore
that accesses the request for recognition of  and
images from then with these five
lines of code we would do we would do everything
is everything that I mentioned before but
each fan can be called if it allows us
that the wheat calls several functions
before well those five lines of code
the function that was called when uploading to
upload that file but I could call for
example a second cloud functions
that for example what it would do to me would be to
resize the photos in case I want to
store them well if I want to show them
on tablets or mobile phones
etc. then I
could have a trigger that will launch  two
functions instead of a single function
those two functions do two
different things one is the so-called pen
image recognition the other is the
processing of images in you to in
different sizes and save them in the
enclave storage so this is what
can be done  what can be done with with
cloud factions in google cloud
what is the difference between an environment
like these function as to be  vice how is
fatigue and what my
colleague jorge has commented just to the session
before that he has commented mainly
app engine
well basically one is about
writing functions are functions that are
executed app engine is about writing
a complete application with many
functions not  then the scaling,
obviously, the scaling is at the
function level in the case of cloud functions and
the scaling from the application level in
the case of the app engine, the pricing of
each faction according to requests, that is,
the google cloud, since it will charge on
it according to  the number of requests that are
called in call factions in app in the
pricing is per minute according to the type
of instance that you configure because the
pricing is per minute then cloud
functions the function is executed when it
comes from a greece tree and when a
trigger launches it  while in the case
of the rock this concept does not exist, the
events if you can,
you can implement them, but only  They are not manual,
for example, if you wanted to implement
the photography example with the app engine,
you would have to talk to cloud storage
to detect when a file is uploaded
and something automatic there that generates the
execution of the function as if it exists
in the cloud in cloud functions and  finally
another difference is the
nokia language support and that is the only one for
now supported in cloud functions a
peñín supports a lot more and of
course to come as it adds another series
of services such as traffic split
investment in etcetera
well this in terms of load  functions
I have commented that there was a second
service that met the four
requirements of being green with the four
requirements of a velez srl architecture
that was fire with fire beige is a
google platform for the development
of mobile applications that fits well
in this definition of  concept of
backend even as a service, that is to say, it is
much more than a cloud function
fire is therefore a bs to a mobile  and it goes
that nothing services that basically what it
allows you is the development of
mobile applications in a
back-end environment that is practically to be true
you do not have to configure you do not have to
worry about anything in the part of in the
back part that  It doesn't have a series of
very interesting features, not
only at the development level, but also
at the implementation level of
applications,
analytics, advertising, testing, but I
'm not going to go into all of the
features, there is a fires session by the
way that is happening
now, but  Well, I think this is going to be
recorded, so you can
access it. I simply want to
highlight three of the characteristics
that fibers have, which are the three
that have been highlighted there, which are perhaps the
most related to cloud functions and
with and with  the server environment is that they are
the real-time database that
has fire you see authentication and cloud
messaging
what is the database in time  for real
what fire has you see in the elba that
basically it is a
non-sql database that is synchronized with
all the devices that are
pointing to it what does this mean
that if I make any changes to
the database it automatically leaves  to
synchronize with all the devices
that are accessing,
so if, for example,
I am the administrator and some
change is made to the database, the
change will be extended to all
devices automatically, it
has a listener, the device has
a lease, which in  four times the
point change is updated even a mobile one
of the mobiles could update the
database and that is where this change would
affect the rest of the other
mobile devices that were
connected it
is in this functionality it
also extends to the environment to the environment  offline
olave the fibers itself handles the cases where
you lose the connection withi
the phone  if the phone
wants to make changes in the database,
these changes are stored in the
local store and when the phone
has a connection again, then out they would
update these changes, taking into
account also the time stand in case
others have updated the database to
at the same time in case of conflicts because
the other would solve it the
interesting services that fibers have the issue
of authentication has an
integrated authentication system integrated with
third parties because like google like facebook
like twitter that allows you to
also develop
mobile applications because it simplifies  a lot
of development time
so later I will tell you about it in the factions topic and the
third of the services is fiver colmex
and ching probably one of the
lesser known but most used services all over
the world because this is the
push messaging system of the entire platform
android this service will
soon display about 25 trillion
messages per month  700 those that we use
today
today we are using android all the
push notifications that we are receiving
from all the email products from
facebook to twitter use this this
service was
formerly called google cloud
messaging it has been integrated into fire page and
now it is called fire plan days inn  but
basically the code and the libraries
are the same it is not a service
that is part of fires that is free
and that allows you to implement
a push messaging system in your mobile applications
I already say
free of charge
so these three things are  three of
the services that fire offers is as
part of the platform and last month
the cloud functions were introduced
for fairways and
why and the concept is similar to the
one you talked about before about crowd fans jones
for gsp what happens what  now the
traders come from the fires products,
that is to say, they can come from the
authentication they can come from here where
yes yes they can't see  nir of the
database in real time, for example,
imagine that someone sees it for the
first time in our application, because
that could launch a cloud functions
that executes my code or someone who
modifies the database, well, if they
modify the database here  of data that could the
fires database I mean the
files database that would produce a
trigger that would execute my code that is to
say the concept of event-based
is the same but this time
the events the triggers come from the
fire products is  that the
fibers services that I have mentioned before then
in I am going to make a demo of the cloud
function for fire is so that you can see a
little the differences priority concept
the concept is the same it is the
launch of the execution of the code
when an event has occurred but
before  to make you the demo of the fire
you see I am going to make a demo of the
database in real time because many
people do not fully understand the
concept of real time  al and then the caf
action I have precisely on
the real-time data base with which
first we are going to do the demo on I
am going to tell you what
the fire's real-time database is you see
well here I have
here I have one  application on the right
I have an application that is launched in two
in the same browsers that is a
normal html application of a lifetime
that basically what it does is send me
a fire message you see the demo above here
no story like that is worth it
in a story like that too much
This application is too complicated because nothing I ran
a normal and current deployed in by the
way in fire page hosting many people
in the hosting of fibers that is
exactly what I deploy from a
deployment of an application of mine at
night and it is taken off well in any
another language displayed on the web gives me
the url and that's fine
then if I wanted to access the
faisal to the text of fire race demo well
nothing here I have the  identifier
of the page title don't inside the
javascript I could with the command
document.getelementbyid
page title access
[Music]
and cam to change the text I do here and
if I display this application again
this javascript is loaded inside the
index dot html yes  deploying this
application is more
if I will deploy this this code because
this code would
change the title instead of putting
elvis demo I would put I would put pp this
first from javascript I tell it because
to facilitate the following well
then what I want to do now is
that yes  someone modifies a base in a
field within a database
in fire veis automatically changes
this text for me
so this
here he
the fire veis database can be
accessed within the fibers console
here I have the cel
here I have the project  and here I have the
console defy I have them in my
database only with a field that is
title and here and a title and with the text
we are in we are in  next then what
I want is that if someone modifies
that text that it will automatically be
displayed in all the
browsers that are
accessing that url all this would be as
simple
as first I have to authenticate myself
in the project  I have the fire you see
okay so I have here these lines of
code
with this I authenticate directly to my
the fire project you see with this command
I access the database
and now the magic comes the magic with
these with these two lines that I am going to
introduce  What I am going to say is if
someone
accesses or modifies the title node of the
database that I have mentioned before,
if the value has to be modified
automatically, what I am going to do is
take that value that has been modified
and it will  change the content of the index
html
snapshot
point,
that is, I repeat if someone will modify me
with these three lines and who will
modify the title value within
the fair race database, well
automatically the object don page title
which is the one with fair play demo would be
modified then save this I will
see that I have not made any mistake
here databases should perfect child point
then with this
where so thank you very much man
if I did not have to hit twice
ok then I will display this and
this will generate a url for me and
we will use the url to access it so
if you would be so kind
to see where I have it
in this url
that I have the project displayed
so if you do it with the mobile
I have  those two lines are also
displayed I am going to make this
small to see
this url is exactly the one that makes
the two windows on the right
we are going to wait for the display to finish,
which takes about 40-50 seconds
it is still there there was a point gl bar  x
lowercase l uppercase w uppercase s
uppercase 4 n
then this will already synchronize all the
mobiles and any changes that
I made within the within the
database pu  it is to modify and automatically
the text
we are going to see how it goes it has already been displayed
in fact
it must have been modified with the
field that was put inside here but
if I now change this
and put the people automatically both
in your mobiles and in the url it
was  here it should be modified
or if I put we are in the session
to see them because the same thing would not be
modified automatically and all the
mobiles would be synchronized and
configured thanks to this base for two and
that you do
nothing automatically and you have to refresh the
device okay then it
works no
your mobiles are
synchronized because it is fair the one that
implements this functionality
so I have told you this is the
real-time database of fires it
has not put me with cloud functions because I
wanted to give you this concept to
explain the concept of cloud  functions
for fire you see then with cloud
functions for fire you basically see
what it is  that any
modification that someone made in this
database could throw me the wheat
and execute me and execute
the code so I have a cloud
functions already deployed already deployed
that basically what it does is that
when I put a text in English here I get
it  automatically translates into Spanish
but if I write this this launches an
exact trigger launches a trigger that
automatically performs the translation
of a text into Spanish for me this
what this has been a cloud functions that
I have already deployed before and what
basically does it  what I did has taken out
inflections that in the title 2 object
when I write something it automatically
launches the Spanish translation
so
this is the concept of cloud function
within fiverr basically it is
similar to the can factions in boss but the
triggers are associated with
fair products  beige that can be
authentication, for example when
someone authenticates, so I do
something for example  example send
a notification a push notification with the
facebook system itself where if ching or well
if it is written with the database
then I do something with that with that
text cloud functions in gsp and fire you see
are not comparable concepts because
fibers is much more than the cloud
function or cloud fast in gcp because
we have already seen what it was, they are functions,
pieces of code that are executed based
on events fibers is a platform is
a platform that includes crowd
functions and many more things
libraries for it  development of
mobile applications in android in uncles
a jason database in real time
like the one we have seen and a support
for languages much greater than that of nokia
and I hope fire is as such it included inclu
ed cloud functions and therefore it is al
o interesting to explain it  well
and to finish I am going to conclude with the
last demo that does what it does the
following is a cloud functions that
well it is an
interesting application  that is integrated with a
send sms provider to send
sms messages to mobiles that basically
what I have implemented is if you
send an sms message to this to this
number the following will happen this
is linked to a twitter account
that is a  sms provider they can
support web books that is to say with which
every time someone sends an sms message they
will launch a song that I have
configured my gsp project is in that
text the text that you are going to send the
sms will receive it  the cloud functions and it
will send it to the natural language processing
and it will take an emoticon according to what
was exposed in the text if you put
I am happy to generate a
happy emoticon if you are sad or if you put
I don't like it then it will generate a
emoticon such and such and that message is going
to put it on one we are going to put it on a
web page simultaneously wait
we launch to launch I think we will
put the screen
so here you see the screen yes  you are
so kind now now yes and you can
send messages in real time
all the text messages
that you are going to send will enter processed by the
natural in guys processing and translated
to the little face that you see there then the
new little faces that are appearing are
the messages that you are
sending the text is one of the texts
that takes one of the words that it
takes and goes and publishes it
directly there in one,
it is putting it in that quadrant through
the mind because of the resolution of the
screen  but normal is that it is seen on the
screen in full screen so
this has been done with 2030 lines of
code nothing else again I repeat a web
that I have configured in me in
July
that launches a cloud functions and a
fast and logical bag is the  text of the sms he
sent it to the natural in guys processing he
asks for more in learning from google that
returns me an emoticon with a face
and those are the answers that I am
getting no well
there we see it are your messages
that are entering in real time with what
you are going with what you are going to write
sorry that it appears it is because of the
resolution of the screen if normally it would
appear in the whole in the whole
extension
this also because I have it
integrated with  beat query these little
messages that you are sending me
I am also sending them to big query to
the database and I can consult, for
example, the different ones if we go to
aviv query
victor and that our
analytics service I have here the database
all the little messages that  you are sending me it
reaches the bit query and for example I have
a query here that tells me well
the adjectives that you are putting in
the messages then well there are
seven that you have made happy one
handsome another serious brutal sad you are
taking the main adjectives  and
it is putting them in vic query because it
is also I am sending the messages to
link and thus not only to the
processor and to the natura  l in guys process
and he does not ask for it more in learning but
also to the bit query which is a bit
what explains this architecture to see
how we go with the logos he is already
filling it like this the curious thing is that
later if this is printed in  video and I am
receiving a message then in the
following days people are
sending me messages all and it continues to
work
well
well this is to be at the presentation
remember the four attributes of one
the four attributes of a
server architecture must be based on
events  the servers that scale and pay
per use then within these well
this would be let's say a 100%
ser velez architecture and the beige aven well the other
three we could also consider it as
a velez srl architecture and in what would
define this range of
products and  Without further ado, thank you for your
assistance and I am here available for
any question I may have
[Applause]
[Music]